I wanted to ask you to UM because you do
so much stand-up you know so you did
fight in the UFC it's so funny because
when I didn't know like I have my kind
of a big UFC fan and when I saw you
perform before I even knew that you were
in that UFC I saw you to stand up so in
my head and I knew that you were doing a
podcast with Kalin so I went on to UFC
that my fight pass on my iPad I the
first fight I got oh he fights and the
die almost dies in that one yeah I
forgot which one but I remember like the
first prior Nogueira wonho's it could
have been yeah yes impale was probably
who wrote you Roy Nelson yeah because I
was probably the one guy knew who Roy
Nelson was really I mean I listen I've
gotten some comedians podcast where it
supposed to be County podcast and they
just talk like real X's and O's about
fighting which I hate yeah I'm not doing
I'm not saying you are I'm not Cena but
now I'm so far removed from it yeah I
don't really care especially with Bobby
Bobby it's a free pass what the hell he
wants to do you and that's not great no
yeah no I saw you bring up feels real
world shitty nobody we just been over
this nobody yeah
hey bring the highlights I wasn't doing
that I was just being honest yeah so you
went to it I want that Fight Club you
almost died okay and I'm like oh that's
why he's doing comedy you know I mean
but that's not the truth because then I
saw other fights and you were good yeah
I mean yeah definitely one more than I
lost yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah okay and
that's someone's do you in the [ __ ]
question I was gonna ask you the
question I was gonna ask you is because
I was I know it's nothing compared to it
but I was on a wrestling team in high
school
okay now you used to do these
tournaments and I remember being so
nervous cuz I had to cut weight and I
don't know there was ask my brother my
brother
in what weight class you were in 98
pounds high school high school high
school independence I was a little guy
I'm genetically small okay you guys
would have shamed me nothing wrong with
that thank you so much biggie at the
wrong
thank you thank you yeah you know what I
like you man then you and I should do
like a movie work the big guy little guy
kind of you could be a quarter of Asian
maybe yeah yeah yeah you could be yeah
yeah be whatever yeah but you know that
so did you get nervous before UFC five
[ __ ] yeah it's terrified really
terrified but is it different than the
kind of nervous you would get when you
did stand out what's more nerve-racking
uh different because then when I was
fighting UFC it's like it's a terrified
feeling I'm not terrified to do stand-up
I'm scared about failing but I'm not
terrified then also let's say I was set
tonight at the Comedy Store let's say I
bomb that I can jump over the improv and
kind of redeem myself in fighting I'm
terrified cos a if I make a mistake I'm
gonna get really really hurt I'm getting
really hurt and I'm getting embarrassed
in front of all my family and friends
and I'm getting half my paycheck and
it's gonna make it harder for me to get
a title shot you know and I'm end up in
the hospital right and it's just that
the stakes are so high Wow it's like
it's the paying business so when you go
into a fight you're gonna get hurt even
if you win you're getting hurt so it's a
tough gig man yeah it's a really really
tough game no so people are really quick
to jump ship I think when a comedian has
a bad set that's generally forgivable
but someone like you is like I consider
it to be like a fair weathered fan where
you're like you wanna you wanna you
wanna and you want to lose this once and
you're out but that's how it is but in
comedy now to that point in fighting
they can be that way and then that
fighter might fight six months later you
know tune in and watch if Bobby really
says a special and it's a dog [ __ ] those
people are gonna judge the [ __ ] out of
them it's gonna jump off Bobby ship it's
true right that's true but I'm talking
about just a regular Comedy Store set
where you're like oh you're working out
material
like room to right but not but he's also
so I don't mean interrupt you but he's
also so so cemented as that so [ __ ]
good at comedies like one of the
funniest guys in the world and also no
one wants to follow Bobby so ah my god
this is all true so I had to form
another items terrifying so if Bobby has
a bad set he's so like he's almost like
it's like Anderson Silva right ever so
it looks like dog [ __ ] right now yeah I
don't like you you put in so much work
in so much history yeah it was good yeah
DC's good John Jones is good Connors
good these get certain guys
Bwana's good yeah she is probably over
for if she's fine
yeah here's a but the but can I just say
about that Johanna thing all right it's
just that it's not the first it's the
second time she lost the second time
second time she lost there's something
that happened with Johanna where I hands
fair that she when she was living in
Poland she was winning before she had a
stylist she's wearing those [ __ ]
polos right yeah yeah yeah then all of a
sudden she becomes like champ or she
lose that one then she has a stylist she
says like makeup on my [ __ ] yeah and
she's all working up her titty yeah
Instagram I see her on a boat with like
we're taking photos of her feet yeah
like her can't it's yeah you're right
I'm not a good way I knew she was gonna
lose I knew she was gonna did you really
yeah yeah not only because of that but
she didn't own it mentally men she lost
that fight and she blamed on everyone
but herself
yeah playing around her trainer a
nutritionist right everybody but didn't
own the law so and she's [ __ ] that
next one
Wow and then she's lost three now right
in a row she fought somebody she was
three in a row 125 that wasn't at yep
I'll be but this is a loss though to the
fans you thank you Brennan you know
thank you so much
to be though the reason why I liked her
so much is because she was so much
superior over her competition at a point
I liked watching that I liked watching
some like watching greatness when a guy
somebody is just so good to write that
they're like untouchable like if I'll
really lunch yeah me too
I'll real watch like some older Jon
Jones finds or older
Anderson Silva fights because I just
like you know that I like some when
somebody's dominant I like the idea that
there's something like almost magical to
it yeah like when Connor was going on
his run on before when John's gone his
run style benders doing that now they
can go back and watch these fights and
it's almost like a higher being what
they're doing so it makes me believe
there's something else out there yeah
then when they lose like [ __ ] yeah but
um but it's so funny that you were able
to like know what happened in terms of
what made you quit UFC and then go into
comedy uh fighting happened just cuz I
had no other options I'm not naturally a
born fighter I don't like to fight I'm
not aggressive person I don't like to
hurt people I can I ask honestly telling
you something what I was saying who I
said this to like Andrew Santino or
somebody like that and we're talking
about you and I said - III go I can't
believe that dude even fought in the
first place I can't either
cuz he's such a soft nice kind of a
gentle you really are a gentle giant
I've always been and I'm a being and
training my coaches like ya get meaner
man you got you gotta hit the gun like I
don't want to hit them like you have to
yeah to me though they kind of they were
smart about they spun it with as like
it's just saw athletic competition man
just beat that guy yeah I heard him yes
beat him and that I didn't have that
mean streak in me was never there there
was one fight I saw you do where you got
knocked out or watch I was gonna cry
because um you would just look like boo
yeah yeah
look oh this is my friend you know man
I'll watch back now if they replay a
fight on TV or whatever yeah Espeon I'll
watch around Greg I don't I don't know
that guy I've no I can't believe I heard
you're different you know it's I my
hat's off to you I really am being
honest and I'm you know I'm gonna say
this right now and I'm getting emotional
um that tell me if this is real emotion
or if he's a zombie
cuz he's a good actor no I'm being real
is is that um it's almost important when
I see skies like you there's only a
couple examples Christina this here's an
example you're an example Theo's an
example there's only a few examples of
people who were doing something else
right and then rate that you were able
to reinvent themselves but here's the
thing folks the reinventing part happen
it doesn't happen right away you have to
fail four years in a row which is what
you did right like I remember when Theo
I started seeing him come around he
wasn't the guy he is now no way he was
just figuring it out but but to do that
to be brave enough to make a choice like
that and then to become funny dude I'm
telling you right now you're you're like
getting spots that are like prime spots
at a rooms in LA that's [ __ ]
difficult to do dude like you know I
took me years to be able to get at like
a Saturday night
laughs actor you know I'm ashamed of it
I'm almost I'm super self-conscious
about it because I feel like because
they'll go hey can you post something
like do I have to tell every when I get
this spot like can you just why I don't
know no cuz I didn't put in the same
work you did no no you can't you can't
think that way because here's a deal bro
is it that if it was just you going from
the UFC straight to stand up if that was
it maybe but no yeah because what you
did also was Bryan Callen okay Bryan
[ __ ] Callen is one of the funnies and
we have to agree on the one of the most
intrinsically funny guys
you ever meet in your life I was on
Island and I could pick for people to
live forever he wouldn't be on it but he
wouldn't because after a week yeah yeah
yeah I want to kill him yeah yeah if
there was a thousand people I got to
choose
he's one of the thousand okay that's
fair that's fair yeah you don't have to
see him no yeah you can still live on
the other side of the island yes but he
has always been one of those guys were
like oh my god this guy's so he asked
you know if you've met him everyone
knows so much time he has so much depth
but he did a podcast before fighter than
kid and he had enlist
yeah which I did and I remember saying
to myself driving there I was like we
have to do he's a friend you didn't try
to troll I know I didn't rely I know I
did to rely by saying but I wasn't a fan
of a podcast about random as a company I
try lied there right and I remember
doing it going right and then one day I
hear I see a post or something about
fire than the kid didn't know what it
was and I realized oh it's Callens new
thing with this guy thing I've seen this
guy around this big guy so when I'm and
then it become it became a hit yeah and
you I think you have the funniest moment
on that he buries it you have the
funniest moment on there every time I
give them a lasted I'm telling you it's
the hardest I've ever laughed and I kept
interrupting so yeah you go back oh yeah
make it worse the station words that was
a funny moment podcast where everyone is
obligated to give him gifts on the day
that molested we get fans that's when I
believe in November 19 or something
[Music]